what do you think about Elon buying
Twitter what do you like um
what are you hopeful on that front what
would you like to see Twitter improve so
I'm very hopeful about Elon buying
Twitter I mean I think that
Elon is significantly more transparent
than what has taken place up till now he
seems committed to the idea that he's
going to broaden the Overton window to
allow for conversations that simply were
banned before everything ranging from
efficacy of masks with regard to covid
to whether men can become women and all
the rest a lot of things that would get
you banned on Twitter before without any
sort of real explanation it seems like
he's dedicated to at least explaining
what the standards are going to be and
being broader and allowing a variety of
perspectives on the outlet which I think
is wonderful I think that's also why
people are freaking out I think the the
kind of wailing and gnashing of teeth
and wearing of sackcloth and Ash by so
many members the Legacy Media I think a
lot of that is because
Twitter essentially was an oligarchy in
which certain perspectives were allowed
in certain perspectives just were not
and that was part of a broader social
media reimposed oligarchy in the
aftermath of 2017. so in order for just
to really understand I think what what
it means for Elon to take over Twitter I
think that we have to take a look at
sort of the history of media in the
United States in two minutes or less the
United States the media for most of its
existence up until about 1990 at least
from about 1930s until the 1990s
virtually all media was three major
television networks a couple major
newspapers in The Wire Services I ever
had a local newspaper with wire services
that basically did all the foreign
policy and all the national policy
McClatchy Reuters AP AFP et cetera so
that Monopoly at oligopoly existed until
the rise of the internet there were sort
of pokes at it and talk radio and Fox
News but there certainly was not this
plethora of sources then the internet
explodes and all of a sudden you can get
news everywhere and the way that people
are accessing that news is
you're I believe significantly younger
than I am but we used to do this thing
called bookmarking where you would uh
bookmark a series of websites and then
you would visit them every morning
and then uh and then social media came
up and it's on AOL or yeah exactly you
had the dial up and you'd actually
there's actually a can connected to a
string and you would actually just they
would go
and and uh and then uh there came a
point where social media arose and
social media was sort of a boon for
everybody because you no longer had to
bookmark anything you just followed your
favorite accounts and all of them would
pop up and you followed everything on
Facebook and it would all pop up and it
was all centralized and for a while
everybody was super happy because this
was the brand new wave of the Future
made everything super easy suddenly
Outlets like mine were able to see new
eyeballs because it was all centralized
in one place right you didn't have to do
it through Google optimization you could
now just put it on Facebook and so many
eyeballs were on Facebook you'd get more
traffic and everybody seemed pretty
happy with this Arrangement until
precisely the moment Donald Trump became
president at that point then the sort of
pre-existing supposition of a lot of the
powers that be which was
Democrats are going to continue winning
from here on out so we can sort of use
these social media platforms as ways to
to push our information and still allow
for there to be other information out
there the immediate response was we need
to re-establish this this siphoning of
information it was misinformation and
disinformation that won Donald Trump the
election we need to pressure the social
media companies to start cracking down
on misinformation and disinformation and
actually see this in the historical
record I mean you can see how Jack
dorsey's talk about Free Speech shifted
from about 2015 to about 2018. you can
see Mark Zuckerberg gave a speech
Georgetown in 2018 in which you talk
about free speech and its value and by
2019 he was going in front of Congress
talking about how he was responsible for
the stuff that was on Facebook which is
not true he's not responsible for the
stuff on Facebook right it's a platform
is ATT responsible for the stuff you say
on your phone the answer is typically no
so when that happened all of these
because all the eyeballs have now been
centralized in these social media sites
they were able to suddenly control what
you could see and what you could not see
and the most obvious example was
obviously leading up to 2020 the
election and that the killing of the
hunter Biden story is a great example of
this and so Elon coming in and taking
over one of the social media service and
saying I'm not playing buyer rules right
there's not going to be this sort of
group of people in the halls of power
who are going to decide what we can see
and hear instead I'm going to let oh
thousand flowers bloom there will be
limits but it's going to be on more
case-by-case basis we're going to allow
perspectives that are mainstream but
maybe not mainstream in the halls of of
Academia or in the halls of media let
those let those be said I think it's a
really good thing now that comes with
you know some responsibilities on
anilon's personal part which would be
you know to be
for example I think more responsible and
dissemination of information himself
sometimes right like he got himself in
trouble the other day for tweeting out
that that story about Paul Pelosi that
was speculative and untrue and I think I
don't think what he did is you know
horrific he deleted it when he found out
that it was false but and that's
actually free speech working right he
said something wrong people ripped into
him he he realized he was wrong he's
elated it which seems to be a better
solution than preemptively Banning
content which only raises more questions
than it than it actually stopped
with that said as the face of of
responsible free speech
you know and and that's sort of what
he's pitching at Twitter he I think
should enact that himself and be a
little more careful in the stuff that he
tweets out well that's a tricky balance
uh the reason a lot of people are
freaking out is because one he's putting
his thumb on the scale by saying he is
more likely to vote Republican he's
showing himself to be center right and
sort of just having a political opinion
versus being this amorphous thing that
doesn't have a political opinion
um I think if if I were to guess I
haven't talked to him about it but if I
were to guess he's sending a kind of
signal that's important for the Twitter
the company itself because if we're
being honest most of the employees are
left-leaning so you have to kind of send
a signal that like a resisting mechanism
to say like uh since most of the
employees are left is is good for uh for
Elon to be more right to balance out the
way the actual engineering is done to
say we're not going to do any kind of
activism activism inside the engineering
if if I were to guess that's kind of the
effective
um aspect of that of that mechanism and
the other one by posting the Pelosi
thing is probably to expand the Overton
window like saying we can play we can
post stuff we could post conspiracy
theories and then through discourse
figure out what is and isn't true yeah
again like I say I mean I think that the
that is a better mechanism in action
than what it was before I just think it
gave people who hate his guts the
opening to to kind of slap him for for
no reason but I can see the strategy of
it for sure and I think that the you
know the the general idea that he's you
know kind of pushing right where the
company had pushed left before I think
that there there is actually uh
unilateral polarization right now in
politics at least with regard to social
media in which one side basically says
the solution to disinformation is to
shut down free speech from the other
side and the other side is basically
like people like me are saying the
solution to this information is to let a
thousand like I'd rather have people on
the left also being able to put out
stuff that I disagree with then for
their to be anybody who's sort of in
charge of these social media platforms
and using them as editorial sites I mean
they're plenty I'm not criticizing MSNBC
for not putting on right-wing opinions I
mean that's fine I run a conservative
side and you know we're not going to put
up left-wing opinions on a wide variety
of issues because we are a conservative
side but if you pitch yourself as a
platform that's a that's a different
thing if you pitch yourself as the Town
Square as as Elon likes to call it then
I think Elon has a better idea of that
than than many of the former employees
did especially now that we have that
report from The Intercept suggesting
that there are people from Twitter
working with DHS to to monitor quote
unquote disinformation and being rather
vague about what this information meant
yeah I don't think activism has a place
in what is fundamentally an engineering
company that's building a platform
uh like the people inside the company
should not be putting a thumb on the
scale of what is and isn't allowed you
should create a mechanism for the for
the people to decide what isn't isn't
allowed do you think Trump should have
been removed
from Twitter
should his account be restored uh his
account should be restored and this is
coming from somebody who really dislikes
an enormous number of Donald Trump's
tweets
um again he's a very important political
personage
even if he weren't I don't think that he
should be banned from from Twitter or
Facebook in coordinated fashion by the
way I hold that opinion about people who
I think are far worse than than Donald
Trump right people I everyone knows I'm
not an Alex Jones guy I don't like Alex
Jones I think Alex Jones oh I think Alex
should be back on Twitter I do actually
because I think that there are plenty of
people who are willing to say that what
he's saying is wrong and I'm not a big
fan of this idea that that because
people I disagree with and people who
have personally targeted me by the way I
mean Alex Jones has been has said some
some things about me personally that I'm
not real fond of you guys not well we're
not besties no it turns out yeah you
know all I've said is I don't really
enjoy a show he said some other stuff
about the Antichrist and such but that
that's that's a bit of a different thing
I suppose you know even so yeah you know
I'm I'm just not a big fan of this idea
like I've defended people who have
really gone after me on a personal level
have targeted me that
the Town Square is online
Banning people from the Town Square is
unpersoning them unless you violated a
criminal statute you should not be
unpersoned in American society as a
general rule that doesn't mean that
companies that are not platforms don't
have the ability to respond to you I
think
Adidas is right to terminate his
contract with Kanye for example with the
guy
um you know that's but
Twitter ain't Adidas
so the way your stance on free speech to
the degree it's possible to achieve on a
platform like Twitter is you fight bad
speech with more speech with better
speech
and that's
um so if Alex Jones and Trump was
allowed back on
in in the coming months and years
leading up to the 2024 election you
think that's going to make for a better
world in the long term I think that on
the principle that people should be
allowed to do this and the alternative
being a group of thought bosses telling
us what we can and cannot see yes so I
think in the short term it's going to
mean a lot of things that I I don't like
very much sure I mean that's that's the
cost of doing business you know like I
think that one of the one of the costs
of freedom is people doing things that I
don't particularly like and I would
prefer the freedom with with all the
with all the stuff I don't like than not
the freedom